well by the way I will Marty care of
nice to see ya so
revisiting this franchise this story has
I've been coming back to the response
you've got to the season one is a
hundred center runs man how does it feel
to have that kind of response to this
well it's just like the movie I mean
nobody knew what the movie had in store
I mean we all did the movie I think all
of us hated the old story was that we
all hated that title Karate Kid we
thought it was a Bruce Lee movie and
certainly nobody expected you know the
success that that film projected you
know it's really incredible in here I
really thought that the writers were
really intelligent and had a really good
hook on everything after I met them a
year ago and that was my contact with
them and they sold me on the whole thing
and when I should come in episode 10 and
why and all that and they were really
intelligent and they were really
perceptive and I really thought this
would this could work
if these these cats literally represent
their talent over these next 10 episodes
that they have planned it should be a
success and it was but nobody ever
thinks of a movie a successful movie
translating into a TV series they never
think it hasn't been done a long time
well we've done successfully like to do
it kind of properly in a way that the
audience responds to so off of that how
do you then jump into season 2 and try
to top that or continue at least with
them any momentum you have well for my
character you know my association with
with Billy's character it was johnny is
it's it's new because it's been
projected how much I loved him over the
years and how much I how many mistakes I
made over 30 years of in absence and
then the only thing I love more than
Billy which is what I've been
entertaining and hearing from the
writers and they're putting it into the
script
it's Cobra Kai I mean it's the only
thing that sort of supersedes Billy
is you know my love for him and he was
my best student and I was always so
proud of him and then I drifted off into
insanity trying to make sure he wins
everything
and we just shot that scene recently and
then it comes around to how much
integrity he has in regard to Cobra Kai
and it's an uncontrollable deal for John
crease it it's it's what he saw in
Vietnam projects no mercy every time I
think that the character allowed himself
to show mercy in Vietnam there was a
little boy with dynamite strapped on his
chest and his entire platoon would go up
and blow up because he showed mercy on a
little kid in Vietnam and that won't
happen again in his life ever you know
when people see you in the street and
you get approached with regard to this
role specifically is there any sort of
one-liner that people will say to you
when they see you that they that comes
to mind with this for the series well
they always say you know
sweep the leg oh they say no mercy you
know but the real intelligent people
they come up and they talk about how
much they love the arcs of the
characters how much they love that
everybody in this series is gray
nobody's no white hats no black hats
which is probably why the Western is
having such a hard time because you know
it's white hats and black hats and we're
all we've grown up on in the western
movie forever but you know Haydn and
John and Josh wrote these characters all
these kids wrote them all with arcs and
they were all having tough times in life
and even if the karate champions they're
having problems socially just like the
original Karate Kid everybody hooks into
the original Karate Kid because you are
there 1984 had a romance that didn't
work you were a fish out of water or you
know you were you basically were bullied
so and and Billy and I often hear that
in panels and autograph shows that's
what they adhere to most you know those
three elements in a movie in our movie
and so talking about that gray area that
everyone has
to have in this this franchise do you
think that excuse me having the team
from the original so many of them back
for this a big part of the success
formula for a Cobra Kai well our writers
look at this as their Star Wars so you
know bringing back everybody and the
brilliance of what of their love the
brilliance of their love is that they
went back into the archives at Columbia
and picked angles for the series that
was still shot for the movie but not
used so they went back and you know got
all these great angles that everybody's
gonna say I saw that and identify with
it but the bottom line was they really
didn't see that cut you know they didn't
see that angle so I think you know it
works very well with the fact of
bringing in characters and then putting
in little bits and pieces from the movie
about those characters you know and I
think I think it's endearing to
everybody I think it makes everybody
feel really good seeing bits and pieces
of The Karate Kid because it all meant
so much to them 30 years ago and it's a
it's a it's kind of a you know failsafe
formula so having so many of these
elements coming back as well for the
TV show and you coming back as well do
you think I only came back because Billy
came back well there you go I just pick
me people come back
[Laughter]
you